when I see you on TV and I look at that
scene right there I would kill to be
have that look to be able to summon that
look that you're giving me right now no
just those eyes if you look that way
those are just man I bet you they get
you your fries faster than everybody
else at the counter don't you think the
thing is is like they kits a family
crime drama about a bunch of tough guys
that robbed banks they do crazy stuff
while they get bossed around by their
mom play tonight Ellen Barkin they cast
me as the toughest of them all can you
believe that grace yes no I can when I
look at you
I can believe it because you've got
you've got a menace in your eyes there's
no menace in my eyes the thing with me
was like I didn't feel tough so I
thought what is tough like a wolf is
tough right so if I could get the eyes
right then I fooled them into thinking
right there into three right there on
the screen if you get the eyes right get
the eyes right then you can just skip
the gym yeah you try this right now
[Applause]
I got you win I can't do that for a
second no one's ever been intimidated by
me in any way which is why I'm always at
the gym I'm not I mean we're like a
couple of Irish clowns like a cleaner no
you you've got the real gravitas you can
and you know what it's in the genes you
posted a picture of your son he looks
like he's channeling you as your
character look at him is he selling
newspapers in the depressions any work
I'm gonna put yeah I'm gonna put you in
timeout he said I will cut you yeah
you wonder why he acts like that and
then you see you know yeah dress like
Marlon Brando no he looks he looks
fantastic and he's got that seam he
could do the same look he looks amazing
we were going to a Christmas party at
John Wells who executive producer has
the show and we said let's go there
they're gonna have some neat stuff he
said are they gonna have any weapons
I've got something to worry about
you